hey guys it is the eighth of me today my
name is Jess McDowell and the show
you're watching is games but you be sure
to stop at the gift shop on your way out
first up all the delays are happening in
the first is hit open world ps4 and xbox
one game dying light the zombie heavy
game was originally scheduled to come
out this year but developer techland who
also created Dead Island have said it's
now being pushed off every of next year
as to why Techland have said when we
started the development of dying light
we were committed to innovation we
wanted to give you a freedom of movement
unprecedented in world games after many
improvements and most of hard work we've
now come so close to realizing our
initial vision that we feel we cannot
stop before it's ready the movement
that's being referred to here is the
park core elements of the game so if you
want to run about the zombie infested
world like this then you should probably
settle in for the wait the other delay
that we got word on today was that elder
scrolls online will be taking its time
getting to ps4 and xbox one unconfirmed
reports of the delay had already come
out but now Bethesda has officially
stated the news saying we continue to
work on the console versions of ear so
and game development has been
progressing steadily but we're still
working to solve the series of unique
problem specific to those platforms but
there's to say it's been a challenging
process and that as a result they're
expecting to need another six months to
ensure they deliver the best experience
possible the book doesn't stop there
though as Bethesda say they intend to
make it up to fans by offering gamers
who bought the pc or mac version by the
end of june the chance to transfer their
characters to either console version
once those come out obviously paying
full price to the game twice isn't cool
so the publisher have said that gamers
can get a full digital version of the
game on console for twenty bucks next up
Activision won't call of gb to be as
talked about as Game of Thrones
specifically they want to deliver their
very own red wedding scene in the form
of interactive entertainment whether you
get that reference or not basically what
developers sledgehammer is after is for
the game to permeate popular culture
significantly studio co-founder Glenn
show
field has said it's not just about the
big moments it's about the emotional
moments it's about emotional connections
narrative is extremely important to us
not that it isn't to others but we pay
an awful lot of attention that the
studio are continuing to promise a whole
different innovative call of duty but
let us know in the comments if you think
they're going to deliver on it and last
up a brand new unreal tournament is
coming and it's going to be totally free
and that's actually three and not free
to play epic games have come out of the
woodwork to announce the title coming to
Windows Linux and Mac it'll run on
Unreal Engine 4 and the dev is promising
that it will be true to its roots as a
competitive FPS development is only just
started today so don't expect this one
anytime soon but epic have said we'll
eventually create a marketplace where
developers and modders artists and
gamers can give away buy n sell mods and
content earnings from the marketplace
will be split between the mod content
developer and epic that's how we plan to
pay for the game let me know if you're
keen for this one and why why not in
that commenting section that is it for
me today but do remember that tomorrow
is top five times if you missed any of
the good stuff from earlier this week
check back with me then